merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
de Fran irréconciliaable un risque de
basculement une guerre civile évitée la
récupération la colère la violence la
vengeance qui fait monter la haine alors
qu'on en sait encore si peu voilà la
situation de notre pays depuis le
dramatique décès de Thomas dans le petit
village de crépul j'ai grandi juste à
côté je sais l'importance de ces fêtes à
quel point rythme nos vie et je ne peux
qu'imaginer l'immense douleur et
l'incompréhension de toutes celles et
ceux qui étaient présents Thomas avait
16 ans jamais il n'aurait dû mourir une
fête de village 16 blessés un mort pour
le village de crépool et tous ceux
alentour rien ne sera plus jamais comme
avant c'est pour certains le miroir
d'une partie de la société où l'on
plante pour une moquerie ou encore
l'amorçage d'une guerre ethnique mais de
quoi parle ton depuis une semaine les
ratonades d'extrême droit terrorisent
toute personne qui n'auraiit pas la
bonne couleur de peau la bonne religion
qui n'habiteraiit pas le bon quartier ce
qui se répand c'est la haine des noms
qu'on jette en en pâure impunément les
représailles et vengeance aveugle c'est
du racisme de
l'islamophobie la vérité madame la
Première ministre c'est que cette haine
qui se répand c'est l'aboutissement de
tant d'échec et que la promesse
républicaine n'a plus de valeur parce
queos vos politiques l'ont affaibli elle
n'est qu'un joli discours masquant la
fracture territoriale le sentiment
d'être toujours relégué pour toutes les
jeunesses de France l'ordre l'ordre
l'ordre peine à masquer la jeunesse mis
au pas du SNU les 493 les ministres
devant la justice les bras tendus à
l'extrême droite et les manif pour rien
alors oui je sais les promesses
n'engagent que ceux qui y croient mais
la promesse républicaine n'est pas une
petite promesse c'est la garantie de
notre vivre ensemble le fondement de ce
que nous sommes et à crpol tout comme à
la monnaie on a souvent l'impression
qu'elle n'est pas faite pour nous elle
devrait être votre seu cap vous avez
failli quand allez-vous enfin prendre
vos
responsabilités je vous remercie la
parole est à Monsieur Olivier verrand
ministre en charge du renouveau
démocratique et porte-parole du
gouvernement
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Marie pochon sincèrement en écoutant
votre question j'ai peur que vous soyez
en train de passer à côté de quelque
chose qui se passe dans notre pays j'ai
peur madame pochon que vous n'ayez pas
été à l'écoute de ce que vous et moi
avons entendu hier lorsque nous étions
dans la Drome vous n'étiez pas avec moi
lorsque j'ai rencontré la les habitants
de de crépole et la famille de Thomas et
vous étiez avec moi dans cet
établissement dans ce lycée au sein
duquel vous avez eu deux peurs se sont
exprimés la peur de la jeunesse de
Crépol de voir les amis des assaillants
de Thomas entraîner des représaill à
leur rencontre et effectivement la peur
des habitants du quartier de la monnaie
qui n'ont rien à voir avec les
assaillants sinon qu'ils portent
peut-être des patronymes ou qu'ils
habitent dans le même quartier et qui
ont peur à leur tour de subir des
représailles de la part d'une partie des
habitants madame pochon quand on parle
quand on parle de risque de basculement
la société évidemment ce que nous ne
souhaitons pas et ce contre quoi nous
luttons avec détermination c'est
lorsqu'il il apparaîtrait qu'il y aurait
comme de France qui se ferait face et
qui ne serait plus capable de
communiquer et quand on serait dans la
généralisation je laisse cela madame la
députée aux extrêmes je laisse cela aux
extrêmes vous ne pouvez pas faire le
lien dans la question que vous posez vu
la douleur des familles vu la douleur et
la peur que nous avons ressenti dans la
drô vu la nécessité que la République
soit la hauteur et que la cohésion
nationale soit la meilleure
réponseortter à la haine vous ne pouvez
pas faire le lien dans votre question
avec des choses telles que le 493 ou le
SNU madame la députée ce que la
population nous demande c'est de montrer
que l'État est ferme que l'autorité
républicaine est là que nous sommes
capables d'agir sur les inégalités et
l'état de droit est fort et j'étais hier
avec le procureur qui a pu répondre aux
interrogations et aux inquiétudes de la
population la justice passera jamais une
intervention aussi groupée n'a été aussi
bien réalisée dans des délais aussi
courts neuf personnes ont été arrêtées
en moins de 3 jours les chefs
d'accusation retenus par le procureur
sont passibles pour le l'auteur de
l'assassinat présumé de la peine de
prison à perpétuité c'est cela que la
population a besoin entendre et ce qu'a
dit la première ministre tout à l'heure
et ce que dit à l'envie et à raison
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur que
nous luttons contre ces bandesarmées qui
sèment la pagaille et la terreur dans
nos villes et dans nos campagnes merci
Monsieur le Ministre madame la députée
monsieur le ministre la promesse
républicaine ça n'est pas que l'ordre
l'ordre et l'ordre je vous remercie